modern painting as a symbol the terms
modern art and modern painting are used
in this chapter as the layman uses them
what I will be dealing with to use Koons
term is modern imaginative painting
pictures of this kind can be abstract or
rather non-figurative but they need not
always be so there will be no attempt to
distinguish among such various forms as
Fauvism cubism Expressionism futurism
suprematism constructivism orphism and
so on any specific allusion to one or
the other of these groups will be quite
exceptional and I am NOT concerned with
an aesthetic differentiation of modern
paintings nor above all with artistic
evaluations modern imaginative painting
is here taken simply as a phenomenon of
our time that is the only way in which
the question of its symbolic content can
be justified and answered in this brief
chapter it is possible to mention only a
few artists and to select a few of their
works more or less at random I must
content myself with discussing modern
painting in terms of a small number of
its representative my starting point is
the psychological fact that the artist
has at all times been the instrument and
spokesman of the spirit of his age his
work can be only partly understood in
terms of his personal psychology
consciously or unconsciously the artist
gives form to the nature and values of
his time which in their turn form him
the modern artist himself often
recognizes the interrelation of the work
of art and it's time thus the French
critic and painter Jean bazaine writes
in his notes on contemporary painting
nobody paints as he likes all a painter
can do is to will with all his might the
painting his age is capable of the
German artist France Mark who died in
the first world war said the great
artists do not seek their forms in the
midst of the past but take the deepest
soundings they can of the genuine
profoundest center of gravity of their
age and as far back as 1911 Kandinsky
wrote in his famous essay concerning the
sphere
in art every epic is given its own
measure of artistic freedom and even the
most creative genius may not leap over
the boundary of that freedom for the
last 50 years modern art has been a
general bone of contention and the
discussion has lost none of its heat the
yeas are as passionate as the nays yet
the reiterated prophesy that modern art
is finished has never come true the new
way of expression has been triumphant to
a nun imagined degree if it is
threatened at all it will be because it
as degenerated into mannerism and modish
Ness in the Soviet Union where
non-figurative art has often been
officially discouraged and produced only
in private figurative art is threatened
by a similar degeneration the general
public in Europe at any rate is still in
the heat of the battle the violence of
the discussion shows that feeling runs
high in both camps even those who are
hostile to modern art cannot avoid being
impressed by the works they reject they
are irritated or repelled but as the
violence of their feelings shows they
are moved as a rule the negative
fascination is no less strong than the
positive the stream of visitors to
exhibitions of modern art wherever and
whenever they take place testifies to
something more than curiosity curiosity
would be satisfied sooner and the
fantastic prices that are paid for works
of modern art are a measure of the
status conferred upon them by society
fascination arises when the unconscious
has been moved the effect produced by
works of modern art cannot be explained
entirely by their visible form to the I
trained in classic or sensory art they
are new and alien noting in works of
nonfiction world no objects in their own
everyday surroundings no human being or
animal that speaks a familiar language
there is no welcome no visible Accord in
the cosmos created by the artist and yet
without any question there is a human
bond it may be even more intense than in
works of sensory arts which make a
direct appeal to feeling and
it is the aim of the modern artist to
give expression to his inner vision of
man to the spiritual background of life
in the world the modern work of art has
abandoned not only the realm of the
concrete natural sensuous world but also
that of the individual it has become
highly collective and therefore even in
the abbreviation of the pictorial
hieroglyph touches not only the few but
the many what remains individual is the
manner of representation the style and
quality of the modern work of art it is
often difficult for the layman to
recognize whether the artists intentions
are genuine and his expression
spontaneous neither imitated nor aimed a
defect in many cases he must accustom
himself to new kinds of line and colors
he must learn them as he would learn a
foreign language before he can judge
their expressiveness and quality the
pioneers of modern art have apparently
understood how much they were asking of
the public never have artists published
so many manifestos and explanations of
their aims as in the 20th century it is
however not only to others that they are
striving to explain and justify what
they are doing
it is also to themselves for the most
part these manifestos our artistic
confessions of faith poetic and often
confused or self contradictory attempts
to give clarity to the strange outcome
of today's artistic activities what
really matters of course is and always
has been the direct encounter with the
work of art yet for the psychologist who
is concerned with the symbolic content
of modern art the study of these
writings is most instructive for that
reason the artists were ever possible
will be allowed in the following
discussion to speak for themselves the
beginnings of modern art appeared in the
early 1900s one of the most impressive
personalities of that initiative phase
was Kandinsky whose influence is still
clearly traceable in the paintings of
the second half of the century many of
his ideas have proved prophetic in his
essay concerning form he writes the art
of today embodies the spiritual matured
to the point of Revelation the
arms of this embodiment may be arranged
between two poles one great abstraction
two great realism these two poles open
two paths which both lead to one goal in
the end these two elements have always
been present in art the first was
expressed in a second today it looks as
if they were about to carry on separate
existences art seems to have put an end
to the pleasant completion of the
abstract by the concrete and vice versa
to illustrate Kandinsky's point that the
two elements of art the abstract and the
concrete have parted company in 1913 the
Russian painter kazimir Malevich painted
a picture that consisted only of a black
square on a white ground it was perhaps
the first purely abstract picture ever
painted he wrote of it in my desperate
struggle to liberate art from the
ballast of the world of object I took
refuge in the form of the square a year
later the French painter Marcel Duchamp
set up an object chosen at random a
bottle rack on a pedestal and exhibited
it Jean bazaine wrote a bit this bottle
rack torn from its utilitarian context
and washed up on the beach has been
invested with the lonely dignity of the
derelict good for nothing there to be
used ready for anything it is alive it
lives on the fringe of existence its own
disturbing absurd life the disturbing
object that is the first step to art in
its weird dignity and abandonment the
object was immeasurably exalted and
given significance that can only be
called magical hence it's disturbing
absurd life it became an idol and at the
same time an object of mockery its
intrinsic reality was annihilated both
Malevich's Square and Deschamps bottle
rack were symbolic gestures that had
nothing to do without in the strict
sense of the word yet they mark the two
extremes great abstraction and great
realism between which the imaginative
art of the succeeding decades may be
aligned and
understood from the psychological
standpoint the two gestures toward the
naked object matter and the naked non
object spirit point to a collective
psychic rift that created its symbolic
expression in the years before the
catastrophe of the First World War this
rift had first appeared in the
Renaissance when it became manifest as a
conflict between knowledge and faith
meanwhile civilization was removing man
further and further from his instinctual
foundation so that a gulf opened between
nature and mind between the unconscious
and consciousness these opposites
characterized the psychic situation that
is seeking expression in modern art the
secret soul of things as we have seen
the starting point of the concrete was
Duchamp famous or notorious bottle wreck
the bottle rack was not intended to be
artistic in itself
Duchamp called himself an anti artist
but it brought to light an element that
was to mean a great deal to artists for
a long time to come the name they gave
to it was objet cuvee or ready-made the
Spanish painter Juan Miro for instance
goes to the beach every dawn to collect
things washed up by the tide things
lying there waiting for someone to
discover their personality he keeps his
finds in his studio now and then he
assembled some of them and the most
curious compositions result the artist
is often surprised himself at the shapes
of his own creation as far back as 1912
the Spanish born artist Pablo Picasso
and the French artist Georges Braque
made what they called collages from
scraps of rubbish mocks ants to cut
clippings from the illustrated papers of
the so called
age of big business assembled them as
the fancy took him and so transformed
the stuffy solidity of the bourgeois age
into a demonic dreamlike unreality the
German painter court Ritter's worked
with the contents of his ashcan he used
nails brown paper ragged scraps of
newspaper railway tickets and remnants
of cloth
he succeeded in assembling this rubbish
with such seriousness and freshness that
surprising effects of strange beauty
came about in Peters obsession with
things however this manner of
composition occasionally became merely
absurd
he made a construction of rubbish that
he called a cathedral built for things
tritter's worked on it for 10 years and
three stories of his own house had to be
demolished to give him the space he
needed Twitter's work and the magical
exaltation of the object give the first
hint of the place of modern art in the
history of the human mind and of its
symbolic significance they reveal the
tradition that was being unconsciously
perpetuated it is the tradition of the
hermetic Christian Brotherhood's of the
Middle Ages and of the alchemists who
conferred even on matter the stuff of
the earth the dignity of their religious
contemplation [ __ ] exaltation of the
grossest material to the rank of art to
a cathedral in which the rubbish would
leave no room for a human being
faithfully followed the old alchemical
tenets according to which the sought for
precious object is to be found in filth
Kandinsky expressed the same ideas when
he wrote everything that is dead quivers
not only the things of poetry stars moon
wood flowers but even a white trouser
button glittering out of a puddle in the
street everything has a secret soul
which is silent more often than it
speaks what the artists like the
alchemists probably did not realize was
the psychological fact that they were
projecting part of their psyche into
matter or inanimate objects hence the
mysterious animation that entered into
such things and the great value attached
even to rubbish they projected their own
darkness their earthly shadow a psychic
content that they and their time had
lost and abandoned unlike the alchemists
however men like shredders were not
contained in and protected by the
Christian orders in one sense
shredders work is opposed to it a kind
of monomania binds him to matter while
christianity seeks to vanquish matter
and yet paradoxically it is shooters
monomania that robbed
the material in his creations of its
inherent significance as concrete
reality in his pictures matter is
transformed into an abstract composition
therefore it begins to discard its
substantiality and to dissolve in that
very process these pictures become a
symbolic expression of our time which
has seen the concept of the absolute
concreteness of matter undermined by
modern atomic physics painters began to
think about the magic object and the
secret soul of things the Italian
painter Carlo Kedah wrote it is the
common things that reveal those forms of
simplicity through which we can realize
that higher more significant condition
of being where the whole splendor of art
resides Powell clay said the object
expands beyond the bounds of its
appearance by our knowledge that the
thing is more than its exterior presents
to our eyes and Jean bazaine wrote an
object awakens our love just because it
seems to be the bearer of powers that
are greater than itself sayings of this
kind recalled the old alchemical concept
of a spirit in matter believed to be the
spirit in and behind inanimate objects
like metal or stone psychologically
interpreted this spirit is the
unconscious it always manifests itself
when conscious or rational knowledge has
reached its limits and mystery sets in
for man tends to fill the inexplicable
and mysterious with the contents of his
unconscious he projects them as it were
into a duck empty vessel the feeling
that the object was more than met the
eye which was shared by many artists
found the most remarkable expression in
the work of the Italian painter Giorgio
de Chirico he was a mystic by
temperament and the tragic seeker who
never found what he sought on his
self-portrait 19:8 he wrote at quit a
marble
nisi quote enigma asked and what am I to
love is not the enigma
Kiriko was the founder of the so called
Peter a metaphysical every object he
wrote has two aspects the common aspect
which is the one we generally see and
which is seen by everyone and the
ghostly and metaphysical aspect which
only rare individuals see at moments of
clairvoyance and metaphysical meditation
a work of art must relate something that
does not appear in its visible form
Jericho's works reveal this ghostly
aspect of things they are dreamlike
trance positions of reality which arise
as visions from the unconscious but his
metaphysical abstraction is expressed in
a panic-stricken rigidity and the
atmosphere of the pictures is one of
nightmare and of fathomless melancholy
the city squares of Italy the towers and
objects are set in an over acute
perspective as if they were in a vacuum
illuminated by a merciless cold light
from an unseen source antique heads or
statues of gods conjure up the classical
past in one of the most terrifying of
his pictures he is placed beside the
marble head of a goddess a pair of red
rubber gloves a magic object in the
modern sense a green ball on the ground
act as a symbol uniting the crass
opposites without it there would be more
than a hint of psychic disintegration
this picture was clearly not the result
of over sophisticated deliberation it
must be taken as a dream picture Kirikou
was deeply influenced by the
philosophies of Nietzsche and
Schopenhauer he wrote Schopenhauer and
Nietzsche were the first to teach the
deep significance of the senselessness
of life and to show how this
senselessness could be transformed into
art the dreadful void they discovered is
the very solace and untroubled beauty of
matter it may be doubted whether Kirikou
succeeded in transposing the dreadful
void into untroubled beauty some of his
pictures are extremely disturbing many
are as terrifying as nightmares but in
his effort to find artistic expression
for the void he penetrated to the core
of the existential dilemma of
contemporary man Nietzsche whom Kirikou
quotes as his authority has given a name
to the dreadful void in his saying God
is dead without referring to
Nietzsche Kandinsky wrote in on the
spiritual in art heaven is empty God is
dead a phrase of this kind may sound
abominable but it is not new the idea of
the death of God and its immediate
consequence the metaphysical void had
troubled the minds of 19th century poets
especially in France and Germany it was
a long development that in the 20th
century reached the stage of open
discussion and found expression in art
the cleavage between modern art and
Christianity was finally accomplished
dr. young also came to realize that this
strange and mysterious phenomenon of the
death of God is a psychic fact of our
time in 1937 he wrote I know and Here I
am expressing what countless other
people know that the present time is the
time of God's disappearance and death
for years he had observed the Christian
God image fading in his patients dreams
that is in the unconscious of modern men
the loss of that image is the loss of
the supreme factor that gives life a
meaning it must be pointed out however
that neither Nietzsche's assertion that
God is dead nor Kirikou is metaphysical
void nor Jung's deductions from
unconscious images have anything final
to say about the reality and existence
of God or of a transcendental being or
not being they are human assertions in
each case they are based as Jung has
shown in psychology and religion on
contents of the unconscious psyche that
have entered consciousness in tangible
form as images dreams ideas or
intuitions the origin of these contents
and the cause of such a transformation
from a living to a dead God must remain
unknown on the frontier of mystery
Kiriko never came to a solution of the
problem presented to him by the
unconscious his failure may be seen most
clearly in his representation of the
human figure given the present religious
situation it is man himself to whom
should be accorded a new if impersonal
dignity and responsibility Jung
described it as a responsibility to
consciousness but in Kaneko's work
man is deprived of his soul he becomes a
money keno a puppet without a face and
therefore also without consciousness in
the various versions of his great
metaphysician a faceless figure is
enthroned on a pedestal made of rubbish
the figure is a consciously or
unconsciously ironical representation of
the man who strives to discover the
truth about metaphysics and at the same
time a symbol of ultimate loneliness and
senselessness or perhaps the mana Keeney
which also honked the works of other
contemporary artists are a premonition
of the faceless mass man when he was 40
Kiriko abandoned his Petera metaphysical
he turned back to traditional modes but
his work lost depth here is certain
proof that there is no back to where you
came from for the creative mind whose
unconscious has been involved in the
fundamental dilemma of modern existence
a counterpart akitaka might be seen in
the Russian born painter Marc Chagall
his quest in his work is also a
mysterious and lonely poetry and the
ghostly aspect of things that only rare
individuals may see but Chagall's rich
symbolism is rooted in the piety of
Eastern Jewish Hassid ISM and in a warm
feeling for life he was faced with
neither the problem of the void nor the
death of God he wrote everything may
change in our demoralized world except
the heart man's love and his striving to
know the divine painting like all poetry
has its part in the divine people feel
this today just as much as they used to
the British author Sir Herbert Reid once
wrote of Chagall that he never quite
crossed the threshold into the
unconscious but has always kept one foot
on the earth that had nourished him this
is exactly the right relation to the
unconscious it is all the more important
that as Reid emphasizes Chagall has
remained one of the most influential
artists of our time with the contrast
between Chagall and Kirikou a question
arises that is important for the
understanding of symbolism in modern art
how does the relationship between
consciousness and the uncon
take shape in the work of modern artists
or to put it another way where does man
stand one answer may be found in the
movement called surrealism of which the
French poet Andre Berto is regarded as
the founder kid eco - may be described
as a surrealist as a student of Medicine
Burton had been introduced to the work
of Freud thus dreams came to play an
important part in his ideas can dreams
not be used to solve the fundamental
problems of life he wrote I believe that
the apparent antagonism between dream
and reality will be resolved in a kind
of absolute reality in Sri allottee
Porton grasped the point admirably what
he sought was a reconciliation of the
opposites consciousness and the
unconscious but the way he took to reach
his goal could only lead him astray he
began to experiment with Freud's method
of free association as well as with
automatic writing in which the words and
phrases arising from the unconscious are
set down without any conscious control
for tone called it thoughts dictation
independent of any aesthetic or moral
preoccupation but that process simply
means that the way is open to the stream
of unconscious images and the important
or even decisive part to be played by
consciousness is ignored as dr. Jung has
shown in his chapter it is consciousness
that holds the key to the values of the
unconscious and that therefore plays the
decisive part consciousness alone is
competent to determine the meaning of
the images and to recognize their
significance for man here and now in the
concrete reality of the present only in
an interplay of consciousness and the
unconscious can the unconscious prove
its value and perhaps even show a way to
overcome the melancholy of the void if
the unconscious once in action is left
to itself there is a risk that its
contents will become overpowering or
will manifest their negative destructive
side if we look at surrealist pictures
like Salvador Dali's the burning giraffe
with this in mind we may feel the wealth
of their fantasy and the overwhelming
our of their unconscious imagery but we
realized the horror and the symbolism of
the end of all things that speaks for
many of them the unconscious is pure
nature and like nature pours out its
gifts in profusion but left to itself
and without the human response from
consciousness it can again like nature
destroy its own gifts and sooner or
later sweep them into annihilation the
question of the role of consciousness in
modern painting also arises in
connection with the use of chance as a
means of composing paintings in beyond
painting mocks Aaron's throat the
association of a sewing machine and an
umbrella on a surgical table he is
quoting from the poet the clamor is a
familiar example which has now become
classical of the phenomenon discovered
by the Surrealists that the association
of two or more apparently alien objects
on a plain alien to both is the most
potent ignition of poetry that is
probably as difficult for the layman to
comprehend as the common puratone made
to the same effect the man who cannot
visualize a horse galloping on a tomato
is an idiot we might recall here the
chance Association of a marble head and
red rubber gloves in cadaqués picture of
course many of these associations were
intended as jokes and nonsense but most
modern artists have been concerned with
something radically different from jokes
chance plays a significant part in the
work of the French sculptor Jean Orhan
SARP his wood cuts of leaves and other
forms thrown together at random were
another expression of the quest for as
he put it a secret
primal meaning slumbering beneath the
world of appearances he called them
leaves arranged according to the laws of
chance and squares arranged according to
the laws of chance in these compositions
his chance that gives depth to the work
of art it points to an unknown but
active principle of order and meaning
that becomes manifest in things as their
secret soul it was above all the desire
to make chance essential in Paul Clay's
words
that underlay the surrealist efforts to
take the grain of wood cloud formations
and so on as a starting point for their
visionary painting MOX Ernst for
instance went back to Leonardo da Vinci
who wrote an essay on Botticelli's
remark that if you throw a paint soaked
sponge at the wall in the splashes it
makes you will see heads animals
landscapes and a host of other
configurations ansed has described how a
vision pursued him in 1925 it forced
itself on him as he was staring at a
tiled floor marked by thousands of
scratches in order to give foundation to
my powers of meditation and
hallucination I made a series of
drawings of the tiles by laying sheets
of paper on them at random and then
taking graphite rubbings when I fixed my
eyes on the result I was astounded by a
suddenly sharpened sense of a
hallucinatory series of contrasting and
superposed pictures I made a collection
of the first results obtained from these
frottage and called it East toile
naturelle it is important to note that
Ernst placed over or behind some of
these frottage a ring or circle which
gives the picture of peculiar atmosphere
and depth here the psychologist can
recognize the unconscious drive to
oppose the chaotic hazards of the images
natural language by the symbol of a
self-contained psychic hole thus
establishing equilibrium the ring or
circle dominates the picture psychic
wholeness rules nature itself meaningful
and giving meaning in Locke's ansed
efforts to pursue the secret pattern in
things we may detect an affinity with
the 19th century romantics they spoke of
nature's handwriting which can be seen
everywhere on wings eggshells in clouds
snow ice crystals and other strange
conjunctions of chants just as much as
in dreams or visions they saw everything
as the expression of one and the same
pictorial language of nature thus it was
a genuinely romantic gesture when Marx
ants called the pictures produced by his
experiments Natural History and he was
right for the unconscious which had
conjured up the pictures in the chance
configuration of things
is nature it is with ants natural
history or Arps compositions of chance
that the reflections of the psychologist
begin he is faced with the question of
what meaning a chance arrangement
Christian man and consciousness come
into the matter and with them the
possibility of meaning the chance
created picture may be beautiful or ugly
harmonious or discordant rich or poor in
content well or ill painted these
factors determine its artistic value but
they cannot satisfy the psychologist
often to the distress of the artist or
of anyone who finds supreme satisfaction
in the contemplation of form the
psychologist seeks further and tries to
understand the secret code of chance
arrangement insofar as man can decipher
it at all the number and form of the
objects thrown together at random by ARP
rays as many questions as any detail of
ants fantastic vataj for the
psychologists they are symbols and
therefore they can not only be felt but
up to a certain point can also be
interpreted the apparent or actual
retreat of man from many modern works of
art the lack of reflection and the
predominance of the unconscious over
consciousness offers critics frequent
points of attack
they speak of pathological art or
compare it with pictures by the insane
for it is characteristic of psychosis
that consciousness and the ego
personality are submerged and drowned by
floods of contents from the unconscious
regions of the psyche it is true that
the comparison is not so odious today as
it was even a generation ago when dr.
Jung first pointed out a connection of
this kind in his essay on Picasso 1932
it provoked a storm of indignation today
the catalogue of a well-known Zurich Art
Gallery speaks of the almost
schizophrenic obsession of a famous
artist and the German writer rudolf
kastner
described georg chocol as one of the
greatest german poets continuing there
was something schizophrenic about him it
can be felt in his work there is a touch
of schizophrenia in it
- yes truckle is a great poet
it is now realized that a state of
schizophrenia and the artistic vision
are not mutually exclusive to my mind
the famous experiments with mescaline
and similar drugs have contributed to
this change of attitude these drugs
create a condition accompanied by
intense visions of colors and forms
not unlike schizophrenia more than one
artist of today has sought inspiration
in such a drug the retreat from reality
France mark once said the art that is
coming will give formal expression to
our scientific conviction this was a
truly prophetic saying we have traced
the influence on artists of Freud
psychoanalysis and of the discovery or
rediscovery of the unconscious in the
early years of the 20th century another
important point is the connection
between modern art and the results of
research in nuclear physics to put it in
simple non scientific terms nuclear
physics has robbed the basic units of
matter of their absolute concreteness it
is made matter mysterious paradoxically
mass and energy wave and particle have
proved to be interchangeable the laws of
cause and effect have become valid only
up to a certain point it does not matter
at all that these relativities
discontinuities and paradoxes hold good
only on the margins of our world only
for the infinitely small the atom and
the infinitely great the cosmos they
have caused a revolutionary change in
the concept of reality for a new totally
different and irrational reality has
dawned behind the reality of our natural
world which is ruled by the laws of
classical physics corresponding
relativities and paradoxes were
discovered in the domain of the psyche
here to another world dawned on the
margin of the world of consciousness
governed by new and hitherto unknown
laws that are strangely akin to the laws
of nuclear physics the parallelism
between nuclear physics and the
psychology of the collective unconscious
was often a subject of discussion
and wolfgang pauli the nobel prize
winner in physics the space-time
continuum of physics and the collective
unconscious can be seen so to speak as
the outer and inner aspects of one in
the same reality behind appearances the
relationship between physics and
psychology will be discussed by dr. ml
from France in her concluding essay it
is characteristic of this one world
behind the worlds of physics and the
psyche that its laws processes and
contents are unimaginable that is a fact
of outstanding importance for the
understanding of the art of our time for
the main subject of modern art is in a
certain sense unimaginable to therefore
much modern art has become abstract the
great artists of this century have
sought to give visible form to the life
behind things and so their works are a
symbolic expression of a world behind
consciousness or indeed behind dreams
for dreams are only rarely
non-figurative thus they point to the
one reality the one life which seems to
be the common background of the two
domains of physical and psychic
appearances only a few artists realized
the connection between their form of
expression and physics and psychology
Kandinsky is one of the masters who
expressed the deep emotion he felt at
the early discoveries of modern physical
research in my mind the collapse of the
atom was the collapse of the whole world
suddenly the stoutest walls fell
everything turned unstable insecure and
soft I would not have been surprised if
his stone had melted into thin air
before my eyes
science seemed to have been annihilated
what resulted from this disillusion was
the artists withdrawal from the realm of
nature from the populist foreground of
things it seemed convinced he added as
if I saw art steadily disengaging itself
from nature this separation from the
world of things happened more or less at
the same time to other artists to France
mark wrote have we not learned from a
thousand years of experience that things
cease to speak
the more we hold them up to the visual
mirror of their appearance appearance is
eternally flat for mark the goal of art
was to reveal on earthly life dwelling
behind everything to break the mirror of
life so that we may look being in the
face
Pawel clay wrote the artist does not
ascribe to the natural form of
appearance the same convincing
significance as the realists who are his
critics he does not feel so intimately
bound to that reality because he cannot
see in the formal products of nature the
essence of the creative process he is
more concerned with formative powers
than with formal products piet mondrian
accused cubism of not having pursued
abstraction to its logical end the
expression of pure reality that can only
be attained by the creation of pure form
unconditioned by subjective feelings and
ideas behind changing natural forms
their lives changeless pure reality a
great number of artists were seeking to
get past appearances into the reality of
the background or the spirit in matter
by a transmutation of things through
fantasies surrealism dream pictures the
use of chants etc the abstract artists
however turned their backs on things
their paintings contained no
identifiable concrete object they were
in Mondrian's words simply pure form but
it must be realized that what these
artists were concerned with was
something far greater than a problem of
form and the distinction between
concrete and abstract figurative and
non-figurative their goal was the center
of life and things their changeless
background and an inward certitude art
had become mysticism the spirit in whose
mystery art was submerged was an earthly
spirit which the medieval alchemists had
called Mercurius he is a symbol of the
spirit that these artists divined or
sought behind nature and things behind
the appearance of nature their mysticism
was alien to Christianity for that
mercurial spirit is alien to a heavenly
spirit indeed it was Christianity's dark
adversary
that was forging its way in art here we
begin to see the real historical and
symbolic significance of modern art like
the Hermetic movements in the Middle
Ages it must be understood as a
mysticism of the spirit of Earth and
therefore as an expression of our time
compensatory to Christianity no artist
sensed this mystic background of art
more clearly or spoke of it with greater
passion than Kandinsky the importance of
the great works of art of all time did
not lie in his eyes on the surface in
externals
but in the root of all roots in the
mystical content of art therefore he
says the artists eye should always be
turned in upon his inner life and his
ears should be always alert for the
voice of inward necessity this is the
only way of giving expression to what
the mystic vision commands Kandinsky
called his pictures the spiritual
expression of the cosmos a music of the
spheres a harmony of colors and forms
form even if it is quite abstract in
geometrical has an inward claim it is a
spiritual being with effects that
coincide absolutely with that form the
impact of the acute angle of a triangle
on a circle is actually as overwhelming
in effect as the finger of God touching
the finger of Adam in Michelangelo in
1914 Franz Marc wrote in his aphorisms
matter is a thing that man can at best
tolerate he refuses to recognize it the
contemplation of the world has become
the penetration of the world there is no
mystic who in his moments of sublimest
rapture ever attained the perfect
abstraction of modern thought or took
his soundings with a deeper plummet Paul
clay who may be regarded as the poet
among modern painters says it is the
artists mission to penetrate as far as
maybe toward that secret ground where
primal law feeds growth which artists
would not wish to dwell at the central
organ of all motion in space-time be it
the brain or the heart of creation from
which all functions derived their life
in the womb of nature in the primal
ground of creation where the secret key
to
all things lies hidden our beating heart
drives us downward far down to the
primal ground
what is encountered on this journey must
be taken most seriously when it is
perfectly fused with the appropriate
artistic means in visible form because
as clay adds it is not a question of
merely reproducing what is seen the
secretly perceived is made visible clays
work is rooted in that primal ground my
hand is entirely the instrument of a
more distant sphere nor is it my head
that functions in my work it is
something else in his work the spirit of
nature and the spirit of the unconscious
became inseparable they have drawn him
and draw us the on lookers into their
magic circle Clay's work is the most
complex expression now poetic now
demonic of the chthonic spirit humour
and bizarre ideas build a bridge from
the realm of the dark underworld to the
human world
the bond between his fantasy and the
earth is the careful observation of the
laws of nature and the love for all
creatures for the artists he once wrote
the dialogue with nature is the candidio
scenic one known of his work a different
expression of the hidden unconscious
spirit can be found in one of the most
notable of the younger abstract painters
Jackson Pollock an American who was
killed in a car accident when he was 44
his work has had a great influence on
the younger artists of our times in my
painting he revealed that he painted in
a kind of trance when I am in my
painting I am not aware of what I am
doing it is only after a sort of
get-acquainted period that I see what I
have been about I have no fears about
making changes destroying the image etc
because the painting has a life of its
own I try to let it come through it is
only when I lose contact with the
painting that the result is a mess
otherwise there is pure harmony an easy
give-and-take and the painting comes out
well Pollock's pictures which were
painted practically unconsciously are
charged with boundless emotional
vehemence in their lack of
structure they are almost chaotic a
glowing lava stream of colors Lions
planes and points they may be regarded
as a parallel to what the alchemists
called the Massa composer the Prima
Materia or Kaos all ways of defining the
precious prime matter of the alchemical
process the starting point of the quest
for the essence of being Pollux pictures
represent the nothing that is everything
that is the unconscious itself they seem
to live in a time before the emergence
of consciousness and being or are to be
fantastic landscapes of a time after the
extinction of consciousness and being in
the middle of our century the purely
abstract picture without any regular
order of forms and colors has become the
most frequent expression in painting the
deeper the dissolution of reality the
more the picture loses its symbolic
content the reason for this lies in the
nature of the symbol and its function
the symbol is an object of the known
world hinting at something unknown it is
the known expressing the life and sense
of the inexpressible but in merely
abstract paintings the world of the
known has completely vanished nothing is
left to form a bridge to the unknown on
the other hand these paintings reveal an
unexpected background a hidden sense
they often turn out to be more or less
exact images of nature itself showing an
astounding similarity with the molecular
structure of organic and inorganic
elements of nature this is a perplexing
fact pure abstraction has become an
image of concrete nature but young may
give us the key to understanding the
deeper layers of the psyche he has said
lose their individual uniqueness as they
retreat farther and farther in the
darkness lower down that is to say as
they approach the autonomous functional
systems they become increasingly
collective until they are universalized
and extinguished in the bodies
materiality that is in chemical
substances the bodies carbon is simply
carbon hence at bottom the psyche is
simply world a comparison of abstract
paintings and micro photographs shows
that utter of
action of imaginative art has in a
secret and surprising way become
naturalistic its subject being elements
of matter the great abstraction and the
great realism which parted at the
beginning of our century have come
together again
we remember Kandinsky's words the poles
open two paths which both lead to one
goal at the end this goal the point of
Union is reached in modern abstract
paintings but it is attained completely
unconsciously the artists intention
plays no part in the process this point
leads to a most important fact about
modern art the artist is as it were not
so free in his creative work as he may
think he is if his work is performed in
a more or less unconscious way it is
controlled by laws of nature that on the
deepest level correspond to the laws of
the psyche and vice-versa the great
pioneers of modern art gave clearest
expression
- it's true aims and to the depths from
which the spirit rose that left its
imprint on them this point is important
though later artists who may have failed
to realize it did not always plumb the
same depth yet neither Kandinsky nor
clay nor any other of the early masters
of modern painting was ever aware of the
grave psychological danger he was
undergoing with the mystical submersion
in the tonic spirit and the primal
ground of nature that danger must now be
explained as a starting point we may
take another aspect of abstract art the
German writer Vilhelm Boehringer
interpreted abstract art as the
expression of a metaphysical unease and
anxiety that seemed to him to be more
pronounced among northern peoples as he
explained they suffer from reality the
naturalness of the southern people's is
denied to them and they long for a super
real and super sensual world to which
they give expression in imaginative or
abstract art but as Sir Herbert Reid
remarks in his concise history of modern
art metaphysical anxiety is no longer
only Germanic and northern it now
characterizes the whole of the modern
world read quotes clay who wrote in his
diary at the beginning of 1915 the more
horrifying
this world becomes as it is in these
days the more art becomes abstract while
a world at peace produces realistic art
to France Marc abstraction offered a
refuge from the evil and ugliness in
this world very early in life I felt
that man was ugly the animals seemed to
be more lovely and purer even among them
I discovered so much that was revolting
and hideous that my painting became more
and more schematic and abstract a good
deal maybe learned from a conversation
that took place in 1958 between the
Italian sculptor Marino Marini and the
writer Eduardo DT the dominant subject
that Marini treated for years in many
variations is the nude figure of a youth
on a horse in the early versions which
he described in the conversation as
symbols of hope and gratitude after the
end of the Second World War the rider
sits his horse without stretched arms
his body bending slightly backward in
the course of years the treatment of the
subject became more abstract the more or
less classical form of the rider
gradually dissolved speaking of the
feeling underlying this change Marini
said if you look at my equestrian
statues of the last 12 years in order of
time you will notice that the animals
panic steadily increases but that it is
frozen with terror and stands paralyzed
rather than rearing or taking flight
that is all because I believe that we
are approaching the end of the world in
every figure I strove to express a
deepening fear and despair in this way I
am attempting to symbolize the last
stage of a dying myth the myth of the
individual victorious hero of the
humanists man of virtue in fairy tale
and myth the victorious hero is a symbol
of consciousness his defeat as Marini
says himself means the death of the
individual a phenomenon that appears in
a social context as the submergence of
the individual in the mass and in art as
the decline of the human element when
Rho DT asked whether Marinis style was
abandoning the classical Canon on its
way to becoming abstract Marini replied
soon as art has to express fear it must
of itself depart from the classical
ideal he found subjects for his work in
the bodies excavated at Pompeii ro DT
called Marinis art a hiroshima style for
it conjures up visions of the end of a
world
Morini admitted it he felt he said as if
he had been expelled from an earthly
paradise until recently the sculptor
aimed at full sensual and powerful forms
but for the last 15 years sculpture
prefers forms in disintegration the
conversation between Malini and Rohde T
explains the transformation of sensory
art into abstraction that should be
clear to anyone who has ever walked
open-eyed through an exhibition of
modern art however much he may
appreciate or admire its formal
qualities he can scarcely fail to sense
the fear despair aggression and mockery
that sounds like a cry from many works
the metaphysical anxiety that is
expressed by the distress in these
pictures and sculptures may have arisen
from the despair of a doomed world as it
did with Marini in other cases the
emphasis may lie on the religious factor
on the feeling that God is dead there is
a close connection between the two at
the root of this inner distress lies the
defeat or rather the retreat of
consciousness in the upsurge of mystical
experience everything that once bound
man to the human world to earth to time
and space to matter and the natural
living of life has been cast aside or
dissolved but unless the unconscious is
balanced by the experience of
consciousness
it will implicit reveal its contrary or
negative aspect the wealth of creative
sound that made the harmony of the
spheres or the wonderful mysteries of
the primal ground have yielded to
destruction and despair in more than one
case the artist has become the passive
victim of the unconscious in physics to
the world of the background has revealed
its paradoxical nature the laws of the
inmost elements of nature the newly
discovered structures and relations in
its basic unit the atom have become the
scientific foundation for unprecedented
weapons of destruction and
the way to annihilation ultimate
knowledge and the destruction of the
world are the two aspects of the
discovery of the primal ground of nature
young who was as familiar with the
dangerous dual nature of the unconscious
as with the importance of human
consciousness could offer mankind only
one weapon against catastrophe the call
for individual consciousness which seems
so simple and yet is so arduous
consciousness is not only indispensable
as a counterpoise to the unconscious and
not only gives the possibility of
meaning to life it is also an eminently
practical function the evil witnessed in
the world outside in neighbors or
neighboring people's can be made
conscious as evil contents of our own
psyche as well and this insight would be
the first step to a radical change in
our attitude to our neighbors envy lust
sensuality lies and all known vices are
the negative dark aspect of the
unconscious which can manifest itself in
two ways in the positive sense it
appears as a spirit of nature creatively
animating man things in the world it is
the chthonic spirit that has been
mentioned so often in this chapter in
the negative sense the unconscious that
same spirit manifests itself as a spirit
of evil as a drive to destroy as has
already been pointed out the alchemists
personified this spirit as the spirit
mercurius and called it with good reason
Mercurius duplex the two-faced dual
Mercurius in the religious language of
Christianity it is called the devil but
however improbable it may seem the devil
too has a dual aspect in the positive
sense he appears as Lucifer literally
the light bringer looked at in the light
of these difficult and paradoxical ideas
modern art which we have recognized as
symbolic of the chthonic spirit also has
a dual aspect in the positive sense it
is the expression of a mysteriously
profound nature mysticism in the
negative it can only be interpreted as
the expression of an evil or destructive
spirit the two sides belong together for
the paradox is one of the basic
qualities
the unconscious and its content to
prevent any misunderstanding it must
once more be emphasized that these
considerations have nothing to do with
artistic and aesthetic values but are
solely concerned with the interpretation
of modern art as a symbol of our time
union of opposites there is one more
point to be made the spirit of the age
is in constant movement it is like a
river that flows on invisibly but surely
and given the momentum of life in our
century even ten years is a long time
about the middle of this century a
change began to come over painting it
was nothing revolutionary nothing like
the change that happened about 1910
which meant the reconstruction of art to
its very foundations but there were
groups of artists who formulated their
aims in ways not heard before this
transformation is going on within the
frontiers of abstract painting the
representation of concrete reality which
Springs from the primal human need of
catching the passing moment on the wing
has become a truly concrete sensuous art
in the photography of such men as
francis ave Kaffee ever saw
Switzerland's vana Bischoff and others
we can therefore understand why artists
continued on their own way of inwardness
and imagination for a good many of the
young artists however abstract art as it
had been practiced for many years
offered no adventure no field of
conquest seeking the new they found it
in what lay nearest yet had been lost in
nature and man they were not and are not
concerned with the reproduction of
nature in pictures but with the
expression of their own emotional
experience of nature the French painter
alfred mon SCA defined the aims of his
art in these words what we have to
reconquer is the weight of lost reality
we must make for ourselves a new heart a
new spirit a new soul in the measure of
man the painters true reality lies
neither in abstraction or in realism but
in the reconquest of his weight as a
human being
at present non-figurative art seems to
me to offer the one opportunity for the
painter to approach the
inward reality of himself and to grasp
the consciousness of his essential self
or even of his being it is only by the
reconquest of his position I believe
that the painter will be able in the
time to come to return slowly to himself
to rediscover his own weight and so to
strengthen it that it can even reach the
outward reality of the world
shambo's Ain speaks in similar terms it
is a great temptation for the painter of
today to paint the pure rhythm of his
feeling the most secret pulse of his
heart instead of embodying it in a
concrete form that however leads only to
a desiccated mathematics or a kind of
abstract expressionism which ends in
monotony and the progressive
impoverishment of form but a form that
can reconcile man with his world is an
art of communion by which man at any
moment can recognize his own unformed
continents in the world what in fact
artists now have at heart is a conscious
reunion of their own inward reality with
the reality of the world or of nature or
in the last resort a new union of body
and soul matter and spirit that is their
way to the reconquest of their weight as
human beings only now is the great rift
that set in with modern art between
great abstraction and great realism
being made conscious and on the way to
being healed for the onlooker this first
becomes evident in the changed
atmosphere in the works of these artists
there radiates from the pictures of such
artists as alfred mana CA or the belgian
born painter Gustave San Shi in spite of
all abstraction a belief in the world
and in spite of all intensity of feeling
a harmony of forms and colors that often
attain serenity in the French painter
John uses famous tapestries of the
1950's the exuberance of nature pervades
the picture his art could be called
sensuous as well as imaginative we find
the serene harmony of forms and colors
also in the work of Paul clay this
harmony was what he had always been
striving for above all he had realized
the necessity of nokton
evil even evil must not be a triumphant
or degrading enemy but a power
collaborating in the whole but Clay's
starting point was not the same he lived
near the dead and the unborn at an
almost cosmic distance from this world
while the younger generation of painters
can be said to be more firmly rooted in
earth an important point to notice is
that modern painting just when it has
advanced far enough to discern the union
of the opposite has taken up religious
themes the metaphysical void seems to
have been overcome and the utterly
unexpected has happened the church has
become a patron of modern art we need
only mention here All Saints at Basel
with windows by Alfred Mann se a aussi
Church with pictures by a large number
of modern artists the Matisse Chapel
advance and the church at Odin core
which has works by Jean boozang and the
French artist Fernando J the admission
of modern art to the church means more
than an act of broad-mindedness on the
part of its patrons it is symbolic of
the fact that the part played by modern
art in relation to Christianity is
changing the compensatory function of
the old hermetic movement has made way
for the possibility of collaboration in
discussing the animal symbols of Christ
it was pointed out that the light and
the chthonic spirits belonged to each
other it seems as if the moment had come
today when a new stage in the solution
of this millennial problem might be
reached what the future will yield we
cannot know whether the bridging of the
opposites will give positive results or
whether the way will lead through yet
more unimaginable catastrophes there is
too much anxiety and too much dread at
work in the world and this is still the
predominant factor in art and society
above all there is still too much
unwillingness on the part of the
individual to apply to himself and his
life the conclusions that can be drawn
from art although he might be ready to
accept them in art the artist can often
express many things unconsciously and
without awakening hostility which are
resented when they were expressed by a
psychologist a fact that could be
demonstrated even more conclusively in
literature than in the visual arts
confronted
by the statements of the psychologist
the individual feels directly challenged
but what the artist has to say
particularly in our century usually
remains in an impersonal sphere and yet
it seems important that the suggestion
of a more whole and therefore a more
human form of expression should have
become visible in our times it is a
glimmer of hope
symbolized for me at the time of writing
1961 by a number of paintings by the
French artist Pierre suloj behind a
cataract of huge black rafters there
glimmers a clear pure blue or a radiant
yellow light is dawning behind darkness